hey 42 here the ancient Egyptians are
well known for their supposed curses but
people have been cursing objects places
and even people for as long as we know
most curses are no more than words or
even rumors and usually no consequences
ever come to pass but here's some
documented cases of real-life curses
that actually took their victims to the
grave we start off with a strange one
when you think of curses you probably
think of ancient hidden treasures or
black magic I imagine you probably don't
think of the singer Frank Sinatra known
as the my way killing it's a phenomenon
witnessed in the Philippines over the
past ten years an unusually high number
of people have been killed while singing
Frank Sinatra's my way in karaoke bars
in the Philippines one of the most
well-known cases was in 2007 when a 29
year old karaoke singer was shot dead
while singing my way onstage the
shooters excuse was that the song was
being sung badly in total over ten
separate killings in Filipino karaoke
bars have been linked to the my way song
and hundreds of other karaoke renditions
have resulted in fines as a result many
karaoke bars across the country have
since bans the song from being sung the
Hope Diamond is a stunning large blue
diamonds that was stolen from the eye of
a sculpted statue of the goddess Sita in
India legends tell of a curse that would
befall the owner of the diamond the
curse foretold bad luck and death to all
are touched the diamond for centuries
following its theft the Hope Diamond has
supposedly caused misfortune to all of
its many owners there are numerous
documented cases of such misfortune but
the most infamous include an innkeeper
who
brought the stone from India to Paris
was torn to pieces by wild dogs in
Constantinople a son who stole a jewel
from his father and later committed
suicide a Russian prince named Ivan
cannot have ski who bought the diamond
and was subsequently killed by Russian
revolutionist but whilst he was alive
cannot have ski loaned the diamond to
his lover who was then murdered by Ivan
himself the diamond was acquired by the
Smithsonian Institution in Washington DC
in 1958 and has remained there
undisturbed ever since the 27 club is a
morbid curse that seemed to affect music
legends throughout history there have
been a remarkably high number of
musicians who died at the age of 27
members of the club include Jim Morrison
Brian Jones Jimi Hendrix Kurt Cobain
Janis Joplin Alan Wilson and Amy
Winehouse all of whom died prematurely
at the age of 27 Eva fou alcohol drugs
murder or suicide King Tutankhamun's
curse is possibly the most famous curse
of all time in 1922 in excavation backed
by Lord Carnarvon famously discovered
the hidden tomb of Tutankhamun but less
than six weeks after the discovery Lord
Carnarvon was bitten by a mosquito and
died from infection in total eight
people who were involved with the
excavation of the tomb died untimely
deaths shortly after the crying boy he
was a painting by Bruno and Mario the
painting was mass-produced and was very
popular in homes in Britain between the
60s and 80s but it seems that whomever
hung the painting in their home also
bought a terrible curse upon their house
because firefighters in the UK reported
an alarmingly high number of houses
burning down that owned the crying boy
painting but the weirdest thing about
this mysterious painting is that when
the fire
writers examine the rubble of the burnt
houses the crying boy painting remained
unburned in pristine condition despite
everything else being burnt to a cinder
in all the cases of houses burning down
the eerie painting refused to burn this
led to national newspapers reporting
that the painting was cursed the Bassano
vars was created as a wedding gift in
the 15th century but the bride was
killed on her own wedding night leading
to rumours that the vars was cursed the
vast was then passed down through the
bride's family over several centuries
reportedly causing death for almost all
of its owners eventually a family member
saw the unusual pattern of deaths
associated with the bars and locked it
away the vast wasn't found again until
1988 with a note inside that read beware
this vars brings death but the new owner
took no notice and sold it at an auction
he later died only a few months later
the vars went on to caused the deaths of
three more vars owners over the course
of just a decade at which point it was
buried for God in an undisclosed
location but it's not just objects that
have been cursed curses have been
associated with a handful of Hollywood
blockbusters where harm came to the film
crew during and after production
including The Exorcist
and the poltergeist but the most curse
of them all was the omen shortly before
filming even began the omen star Gregory
pecks son killed himself afterwards on
the way to filming pecks plane was hit
by lightning so was the scriptwriters
plane and the executive producers plan
during shooting the hotel where the
producers were staying was bombed by the
IRA and so was the restaurant that the
directors and actors were scheduled to
eita
also a tiger handler that helped with
the filming of the omen was eaten alive
by the tiger but it doesn't end there
after the filming had finished special
effects consultant John Richardson was
involved in a car crash that killed his
assistant and when Richardson scrambled
out of the wreckage he looked up and saw
a road sign that red omen 66.6
kilometers even the date of the crash
was cursed it took place on Friday the
13th of August 1976
there's definitely something very
sinister about that film thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2